All right. Let's try creating a maintenance ticket and see if this works.
>> Sounds good.
>> So the technician I'm guessing will be me.
>> Yeah. So in this case it has to be you, but I mean, usually
there'll be a bunch of people in an organization, so you could add any user.
>> Okay. the stage will be the Udacity Stage, let's say. Status, New.
Priority high and let's say that the
description is that everything is completely broken.
>> Got your work cut
out for you, Andy.
>> I know. This is bad news. So save.
>> So you should be able to see the tasks
that we've just created from this page. But we'd have to
add that related list of the activities and activity history onto
the page layout in order to be able to see that.
>> Okay, so I'll edit the layout.